[Music]
hello again time then for the press
preview first look at what is on
tomorrow's front pages starting a little
later tonight because of this special
edition of sky news at 10. taking a look
at the headlines with me the former
defense minister anna subri and the
daily mails deputy political editor john
stevens they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight evening to
you both we'll speak in a moment we'll
just check out those front pages
for you of course just one story is
dominating the guardian proclaims putin
invades picturing a woman with a
bandaged head and a blooded face after
an airstrike the same woman is on the
front of the metro which likens
president putin to hitler with the
headline war in europe likewise the
mirror their headline her blood his
hands
the sun has a nearly identical front
page to the mirror in fact the star also
going with the hitler comparison
similarly the express says the invasion
redraws the map of europe in blood
the time says today is a dark day for
europe
here's the ft declaring putin's forces
storm ukraine
the telegraph calls it a new cold war
the eye tells the story of what it calls
ukraine's agony
and tomorrow's mail reports that putin
intends for russian forces to seize the
ukrainian capital kiev
within days and a reminder that by
scanning the qr code that you can see
on your screen joining a program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch and listen to us
and i'm joined now by anna subrey and uh
john stevens um what a day it has been
anna let's start with the front of the
financial times an image there from the
early hours of this morning uh one of
the airstrikes that took place uh close
to
kiev uh so depressing just
summed things up for us um
uh the last 24 hours
i still think like many people i'm in
shock and disbelief i mean i know of
course that this has been
hugely talked about and largely
predicted and it looks like the
intelligence forces have got it right
but for actually to happen i just don't
think we ever we just couldn't believe
that this could happen in our in our
lifetime and it has happened
uh and we can see
uh the consequences of what putin has
chosen to do and as the ft says it's the
largest military advance
since the second world war and it goes
on to describe the scale of the advance
and obviously you've been reporting all
day and all through this evening on how
putin's forces have gathered effectively
around the ukraine
and invaded it in so many different ways
and with devastating consequences and i
obviously heard what deborah haynes had
to say
uh and her words were chilling and i
think that's how we are all today
chilled horrified disgusted
and i think firm in our resolve that we
must now take serious action against
putin
and make it very clear we won't tolerate
this yeah and we'll talk about those
sanctions uh uh in a moment uh john the
front of the guardian uh shows a picture
of a poor woman who's injured in the
street in east ukraine after one of
those air strikes her picture on the
front of a number of papers actually i
mean do you think we underestimated
putin was intending on a full-on
invasion all
along i think the last few weeks putin's
clearly been playing a game with the
west he's had all these leaders and
foreign secretaries etc travelling
to moscow to come and speak to him we've
seen all those pictures of him meeting
leaders at the other far ends of the
table but it looks like whatever the
west had done that this was his plan
all along and as anna said even though
we've been warned that this was what he
was planning to do that he was going to
launch a full-scale invasion is very
much talk different talking about it and
then actually waking up to the news and
seeing the the sheer scale of this you
know with the air land and sea attacks
that he has carried out and obviously
these striking pictures that we're
beginning to see on the front pages of
all the different newspapers is about
the human cost of this and how so many
ukrainians must just be in absolute
terror that this has put them in
complete danger and you know putin was
out again lying today saying that this
was just about taking military bases etc
there weren't there's going to be any
reason that ukrainian civilians needed
to be
concerned but here we've seen a blast
and missile between two five-story
apartments
and you know people's homes destroyed
people's lives ruined and no wonder so
many ukrainians are trying to escape the
country
yeah and uh today
sadly just the start um anna let's look
at the front of the metro uh summing it
up there really war in europe putin
branded 21st century hitler as he
invades ukraine of course putin today
said that this is all about de-nazifying
ukraine which was a rather bizarre
comment
yeah and and totally baseless
it's just an absolute nonsense
but the person who's behaving like a
fascist dictator is putin and i i think
it's really important that we you know
we absolutely lay the blame not with the
russian people but with putin
this is his war these are his actions
and he is behaving in this disgraceful
way and
to to claim that somehow he's doing
something even vaguely noble it's it's
just
the biggest load of nonsense it it
insults everybody's intelligence
uh john the front of the telegraph uh
new cold war as putin strikes um
many are going to be concerned that
putin now is of the mindset that ukraine
is just the start i mean how far is he
going to go
yeah and this was this is a really
concerning thing and there was an
ominous warning from president biden
tonight he was saying that
it looks like putin is trying to
recreate the soviet union and it looks
like his ambitions
could go far beyond ukraine and i think
that's the really difficult thing
for the western knowing what to do
and i think that's why it's so important
that the west isn't soft with the
sanctions that we finally start to see
the tough action that matches the
rhetoric that we've had
from the last few months and we can't
just have a repeat of the last 10 or 10
years when putin's repeatedly taken
actions such as in crimea with the
downing of the mh17 jet with the
scribbles in salisbury and the killing
of dawn sturgis and time after time
after time actually the sanctions that
the west has put on putin has been quite
feeble i think this time we need to show
that we will take all action that we
possibly can so that putin has no choice
but to stop this yeah and in front of
the uh um the eye ukraine's agony uh
another picture there heartbreaking
picture of somebody uh clearly in a lot
of distress but the problem is
russia has nuclear weapons and there's
only so far
we're going to want to push him isn't
that
absolutely and of course he knows that
and he also knows through what happened
with afghanistan for example and the
withdrawal of the american troops and
the failure of anybody to do the right
thing in afghanistan he knows that none
of us want war i mean the people the
people not just of america in our own
country and i think widely do not want
war i think we live in very different
times even from the 80s which obviously
people like me remember when i think
people are under the leadership of say
thatcher and reagan there was more of a
willingness to be that the police
officers of freedom and democracy in the
world and i think a lot of that has now
gone and putin knows all of that and and
my huge fear is that this is indeed part
of a plan i mean after all he has
secured in effect 14 years 14 years more
in power in theory
and although he's 69 he intends to use
those years to execute his plan and i
think you know in the past i think we
all looked at this and i think we were
complacent and i put my hands up as a
member of a government in the last 10
years that we've been too complacent and
when people said oh we got this plan
effectively to reinstate the old soviet
union i think we all boo booed it away i
think it's true i think it's real and
that's why we have got to stand up to
him and we've got to do the right thing
now okay anna john i know you'll stay
with us for the next hour or so thank
you very much for the moment